welcome back uh to down the middle i i
have to say i'm honored this afternoon
that uh that a fishing buddy of mine uh
was willing to take a little bit of time
out of his busy schedule uh to to to
visit with us i'm so pleased to
introduce charles flosser uh he really
needs no introduction he was the
president and ceo of the philadelphia
federal reserve from 2006 uh through
2015.
more recently
he's been with finra the financial
industry regulatory authority uh where
he has positions both on the investment
committee and on and on the finance
operations and technology committee so
um i i see your
you may have retired from the fed but
you certainly have stayed busy and i can
see from the background all the papers
so i'm happy to see you're still
reading copiously um
so welcome welcome it's good and and if
i can i'm gonna call you charlie because
that's that's that's that's what i've
called you all these years so that's
fine it's good to be with you danielle
thank you um
so i i instead of you telling me a funny
story i'm gonna tell you a funny story
real quick before we jump into the nuts
and bolts of
a federal reserve policy so the
afternoon in maine uh when the two of us
uh
were fishing in the afternoon
uh it was such a warm day that i decided
to get into the lake
and what i never did tell you was i was
so mortified because i could barely get
back into the canoe that i ended up with
bruises on the underside of my arms for
six months that they did not go away and
i just remember saying to myself i'm
this is the least graceful moment of my
life is me trying to haul myself back
into a three-person canoe up in grand
lake stream maine um but that was a fun
afternoon and it it is great to see you
um there's a lot to talk about uh so
i'll i'm just i'm just gonna jump in and
by the way uh do you still get to fish
i not i didn't this year
i so i do some but but this year
coverage kind of got in the way of a lot
of things for us
i think i think everybody can say that
covet has gotten in the way of a lot of
things indeed indeed um
well i i'd love for you to take us back
to 2006
um when you when you started at the fed
there was a lot going on at that point
uh the housing market was just quite hot
and
obviously you know in in on the west
coast there was a lot of subprime
mortgage lending going on there was a
lot of financial innovation
going on if you could just take us back
to that time
and and walk us through some of the some
of the signals some of the flags some of
the signposts that you saw in that era
that that started to sit to flash red to
you
well uh
i think you've got it right the the
thing that was flashing red was clearly
housing
in 2006.
um
and um i remember before i started
having a conversation with
some of my
soon-to-be colleagues
it's a fed
um
about interest rates about housing
and um
both the role of the fed
but also uh whether
the fed should or shouldn't be
so to speak doing anything about it
in some sense
and i think there was a lot of
uncertainty
and a lot of uh
i guess i would describe it as as um
angst building up
around the fed as to sort of
uh
how serious was this problem
um
and
uh what the fed
should do if anything about it and um
and that was
uh right after i began at the fed and
um
frankly the first six months it was hard
you just started getting your head
around it and figuring out being being
the new kid on the block so so to speak
sure you know what the right what the
right approach might be so there were
there were red flags
well i won't call them red
warning flags maybe is a better way to
put it
um
in those 2006 discussions and of course
that began to change pretty quickly
certainly when we got into 2007
and um
and further into 2007
uh it became
you know
the flags didn't go away and
the fed began grappling with sort of
what what our role should be
in the in that environment
um so uh
back then uh
you know the fed was only involved with
what we call now i guess conventional
monetary policy the interest rate lever
was you know kind of
the main tool
uh that was used and um
i'll just jump straight to the question
i'm curious
about
whether we truly need it to go to the
zero bound
i think that's a fair question
i think that um
[Music]
my
inclination at the time
was certainly
leaning against going there
i didn't see a particular benefit from
being there
um
and um
i would say that
the zero bound or what they call now the
effective lower bound at zero
has become
an obsession of the fed
and how to deal with that
and it has
colored and
shaped
the entire way they think about policy
and so
um
it's my view that i think
that has not been entirely desirable
um
and um
nor is it is it
um do i want to say as important or as
critical as some people make it out to
be at least in my mind
right
well
you know
the idea of the bernanke doctrine at the
time it was kind of drawn up in in late
2007 at the 2007 jackson hole meeting uh
you know it was the blueprint dictated
that you had to get to the zero bound
before you could launch large-scale
asset purchases or what
the
lay people call quantitative easing qe
um
do you think that that that that
necessarily that one should have
necessarily
predicated the other
and and what were your feelings about
about large-scale asset purchases
well as you know danielle i was never a
big fan of blockchain as a person
yes i guess you definitely dissented i
remember when you were when you were
dissenting and my boss richard at the
time you're both dissenting together yes
um
i i think two things is that
for most of 2007
um
the emergency or
unconventional
policies we adopted
some of which there was the towels
and then there was other other sort of
discount window and and uh primary
dealer lending things that we tried to
put in place in 2007.
the facts of the matter is that
virtually all that
uh
all those efforts
were what we would call sterilized
that is that finance those
by selling
treasuries
as a consequence much of that early
stuff in 2007
um
through most of 2007
was
not expanding the balance sheet indeed
in fact the balance sheet stayed pretty
flat
through most of
2007.
uh and
and uh and even into 2008
um
so um
i think that what happened was two
things one is
particularly after lehman brothers
the fed could no longer sterilize
it was running out of treasury bills to
sell
so
there was gonna have to be uh or and
certainly
yes in ben's mind there was gonna have
to be
a change in the way we did things
if
he wanted to figure out a way to provide
more accommodation
and the balance sheet was going to have
to grow
and
then the question came about well how
would we do that and also
how do we control it once we do it
exactly
and um
that that was a huge debate about how to
go about doing that um
and i don't know that it was so much
being at the lower bound
the lower bound was kind of
a
a reason
to want to do more accommodation and to
figure out a way to do it
but
but remember particularly in 2000 late
2008 after lehman brothers and so forth
and so on
most of the fed's efforts in those early
days
were really about
uh stabilizing the markets
and the functioning of the markets
and that's what came to be known as qe1
right
and yep
and
i didn't have
i had some problems with that but not a
lot uh huey one
were doing what
i think the feds should have done
we did it
magnitude of it but
it was seeking to stabilize markets
but you know
after
i don't know say march or april of 20179
[Music]
it was done
that's exactly when markets that's
exactly when the s p 500 bottom was in
march of 2009 and and so at that point
um
the fed
in my in my view the fed had in essence
accomplished that goal of stabilizing
market function
it was what came after that it was even
more troubling
um qe2 and 3 and 4 or whatever infinity
average whatever the people like to call
it
those were the problems when the fed
switched
from a
market stabilizing role
in financial markets
to actually trying to use
kiwi to provide more
monetary policy accommodation
so there was a fundamental change in the
rationale for cueing
that happened
and that rationale
was what
i opposed i didn't think it was a very
good rationale i didn't think it was
going to work
and i objected to
moving from
flooding the market with liquidity to
solve a market functioning problem
to one that says we're going to flood
the market with liquidity to do monetary
policy
i think it's interesting
that many
people
who thought that was such a great idea
back in 2008 and 9 and 10
many of them are now looking back on
that episode
and i think there's a growing um
maybe it's not the majority but more
people now
are looking back and saying that really
wasn't as effective as the fed thought
it was going to be
i think that's a fair i mean you hear
people talking about this and they've
been papers written on it
and
i mean when you when you look back at
the transcripts of those years you're
right there was very vigorous debate
yes um and you know now i think some of
the people uh i mean the fed doesn't say
this directly but
much of the research that's come out
since then
has now sort of said well yeah maybe
this really wasn't quite as powerful as
the fed made it
thought it was going to be or made it
out to be
of course yet we're doing it again so
that's a different question but um
so uh i think that uh i do separate out
uh both the motivation rationale for um
qe1 from qe2 three and four i just think
it was very different so um it's
interesting because you use the term
rookie
and uh there was there was a rookie on
the board uh
who had only been
been there since i think june and then i
i guess it was october maybe 2013
maybe it was 2012 2013 but it was when
qe3 was being voted
and and
and a very new
uh
jerome powell
argued very eloquently given his
knowledge of the financial markets and
and the word that he used in the
transcripts was that he was concerned
that that qe would become habit-forming
uh and there were
i mean
maybe i need to get out more charlie but
it was one of those fascinating reads
was to go through that entire transcript
again because
because the debate was as as spirited as
as it was as revealed in those
transcripts
well i think that um
those of us who were
on one side of that spirited debate and
um
jay i think if i remember correctly was
very
polite about it but um
i think we all worried and if you
have read them you'll know that many
of my comments
through that whole period was about
once we start this how in the hell do we
get out of it right
there was always that term exit exit
exit and
do we have a plan to get out of it uh
and uh of course
many of the leadership in the fed said
of course we can we'll switch the
balance sheet we'll go back and of
course it never happened
um
and
um there's a whole lot
of
behind that in terms of
what happened with interest on reserves
and
the split between
portions of the fed that really saw
this
big balance sheet as a long-run
operating regime
and
and those of us who didn't like that
idea for a lot of reasons and um
so
uh
i think the evolution from
the
well i'll call the old regime what we
call the corridor system
you know back before 2007
and um
that um
i think if that
desire to go back to that there were
people within the system
and within the board who just didn't
want to do that and of course
that was related to interest on reserves
and a whole bunch of other issues
um and
so it's been a quite a
a long
let me call it evolution
of how monetary policy
evolves and works
and operates
and
i'm not convinced it's been all for the
best
for the better
that that was said that was said very
diplomatically
very impressively indeed um
so let's go to another thorny issue uh
alan greenspan once said that the ideal
inflation rate for
your average u.s household and and
company was zero percent
um
and there was obviously
years and years of debate around
inflation targeting so how did you feel
about that two percent target
well i actually i think
greenspan's what said was that
the price stability
and the target for inflation of the goal
should be inflation never enters into
the household's decision-making
in other words that it was small enough
to be irrelevant for decision making
which
is not a bad way to think about it it's
kind of hard to figure out how to
operationalize that
of course but but uh
and um
so i from the very beginning from day
one when i went into the fed
i was arguing for an inflation target i
mean ben had been too for that matter
uh so i i haven't
i
was very active
in actually
getting the 2012
inflation targeting statement written
i was deeply involved in that uh
and um
wasn't exactly what i would have written
but you know you got to get through a
whole committee
of course
but um
when i started off i would have been
happy
with something like a one percent target
instead of two percent right
but
but frankly the difference
the importance of the target is having a
target that you commit to
that's what's important about it right
and whether it was one and a half
percent or one percent or two percent
was a little bit was less important now
obviously i wouldn't have settled for
four
right but but
you know the precise number was less
important
than
the commitment
and the willing to go publish with the
commitment
and so yes i would prefer something like
a one or one and a half percent target
but having two didn't bother me and
there was some advantage to two
because in fact many other central banks
around the world had adopted two
and there's some rationale in an
international context
to um
have central banks
on similar pages if you will in that
regard
not necessary it's not really
coordination
but it does
it would simplify things so i was okay
with two
i would have preferred the cpi
to pce
and all right
only because
that's actually a big statement
well the the main reason for that was a
from a communication standpoint
the cpi was better known
and the really important thing about it
is it doesn't get revised
whereas the
pce gets revised periodically
and so for those reasons i leave towards
the cpi i mean the yeah the cpi
so um
that would have been my preference but i
was very happy that we did what we did
in 2012.
i think they've mangled it pretty badly
in their august 2020
restatement of their long-run objectives
they kind of thrown out the baby with
the bathwater i think
but um
so i think the 2020 statement
was a step back from my 2012 statement
interesting
um so you were only out of college i
want to say for eight years
uh when the dual mandate was
added to uh to the federal reserve act
um
how do you feel about the dual mandate
today
given uh
given it is causing its own source of
debate
among central bankers because it is so
difficult to uh to target
to minimize inflation and maximize
employment and as we've seen
or at least in my view it's caused the
fed to stay too low for too long
so um
i
i gave many speeches on this topic um
and um
let me take a step back
i think one of the most important
features of a central bank
is independence
its ability to make monetary policy
decisions
as free as possible
from political interference
but to have
an independent central bank
independence
isn't free
that is to say
for a bank to be truly independent
there must be constraints
on the behavior of the central bank
in other words if you if you ask the
central bank to do everything that's an
old expression
you've probably heard before uh
responsible for everything and
accountable for nothing
indeed
and what's happened to monetary policy
and and
in my view
is that we have continued to expand the
mandate in the reach
of what we ask monetary policy and
central banks to do
and in so doing
we are expanding their authorities
making them responsible for all sorts of
things that they really can't do
anything about
that really makes them unaccountable
because they can move their objectives
around and make excuses for doing
anything they want to do which leads to
a lot of discretion
i think that's a bad trend in central
banking i would prefer to see
central banks
i gave a speech and wrote a paper one
time called a limited central bank
where a central bank is more targeted
independent
but more targeted and more accountable
and one way to help do that is to narrow
the mandate not to keep expanding it
because the more you expand it
the more discretion you leave and you
make
monetary policy
unpredictable
and
that i believe is counterproductive it's
counterproductive
um so i think that
um and you may want to get to this later
but again
the revised statement that the fed came
up with last year
was a huge step back
and has now made
the employment side of the mandate the
dominant mandate not price stability
correct and i think that's obvious
not just from their language but when
they said
we will not raise interest rates until
there's full employment or something to
that full inclusive employment full and
inclusive that that is that is just a
statement that says inflation is of
secondary importance to them
and uh so they flipped the mandate to
the extent that price stability was the
most important
and now they are holding themselves
accountable for not just
employment
but
inclusive employment whatever that means
for climate change
i mean you go down the list
of the expansion of the perceived
mandate of central banks
and
ability on the institutions whatsoever
and therefore risk their independence
i'm sorry that was the long answer to
your question but no no no but but you
bring up so many salient points and
you've actually written recently about
this kind of mandate creep
and the the dangers that it poses and i
think i i agree with you i think
independence is critical to the the
sanctity of the institution and we're
getting further and further from that
um
that that kind of brings us to
this this past july
we had the 70th year anniversary of the
um
of the 1951 treasury fed accord
a gentleman by the name of william
chesney martin was involved
in that
and i'm curious
to see
where you feel
the fed and the treasury's
relationship how how that has evolved
over time how that evolved in the heat
of of the onset of the pandemic
and um and whether or not
we should anticipate increased
coordination to better manage the
nation's debt or if we should be saying
you know what let's look back to 1951.
there was it was good reason that uh
that those lines were drawn
um more starkly in between the two
institutions
again i i would go back i think clearly
1951 was an incredibly important time
for the fed
it really did
it really did secure
its independence of monetary policy
in a fairly clear way at the time
compared
compared to the
model where they were taking the
interest rate during the war
and didn't have any freedom at all
and i would say that independence
grew
and
but um
i think that
um
how do i want to put this
they um
it's going in the reverse direction
now
and uh and that's not healthy
i think the fed is losing its
independence
um
and
uh
let's just take
i mean i talked about this back into in
the financial crisis 2008 and 2009-2010
and there i wrote several pieces
uh and gave talks on what i call the
separation of monetary and fiscal policy
how to restore the boundaries between
those two
and
um
i think there are boundaries between
monetary and physical policy for a
reason
and um
and so uh
one of the things that has happened
that
is sort of highlighting this
dilemma or this
challenge
is the fed's engagement in fiscal policy
credit allocations buying up
non-treasury assets
trying to influence relative prices in
the financial marketplace
is all a game of fiscal policy it's not
monetary policy
that is dangerous for the fed to be
doing
they've been pushed in that direction
fair enough but they've also willingly
accepted
the responsibility for relative prices
in the financial system
that's a huge mistake for the fed to be
engaged in
the fed needs to be as neutral as he can
in credit allocations
the emergency
uh borrowing or lending programs in 2008
and 2009 and more dramatically
after the pandemic
the lending buying of corporate bonds
making loans
that is not monetary policy that's
fiscal policy
the treasury or the congress in response
to the pandemic
the cares act and all the programs that
got set into place
that the fed did
all that
all of that could be done could have
been done by the treasury
they didn't need the fed to execute any
of that
and that was a huge mistake because now
um it's thought of as appropriate
actions by the central bank
it's not those are fiscal bailouts
fiscal
fiscal policies that the treasury should
have implemented i mean the feds could
have helped them do it i mean there's no
reason technically
but
they all should have been done by the
treasure the fed didn't have to do
any of them
and that just drags
the central bank deeper into the
political process
and into the conduct of fiscal policy
and
i think it's sad that the fed has been
willing to allow itself to be drawn into
that
it seems to have no interest in
protecting its independence
and man
the treasury secretary mentioned
um mnuchin i mean um
they stopped those programs last year if
you remember the big debate
oh yes paulo said no no you have to we
have to keep up you have to we have to
have this power
um
that's a sad statement about um about uh
about the fed's perceived role
in the government
and i'll make one more point sorry to
ramble on here no no but you you you
allude to the fact that
in many
much theory economics theory and models
you do hear people talk
a lot about
coordination between the treasury and
the central banks if that's optimal
policy in some sense
well yeah maybe in some models there's
optional policy
but what those models don't understand
and don't take into account
is institutions
carl bruner the famous monetary
economist who was a colleague of mine
for many many years
served with him on the shadow open
marching committee and
as i edited the term of monetary
economics that he founded which i edited
for 20 years
carl used to make a very important point
he said to understand policy
and recommend good policy
you have to understand the institutions
the institutions matter
and the way they're designed
and the incentives
that arise within the institutions
because of the way they're put together
affects the way policy gets conducted
and so when you when you want to think
hard about policy
the notion that you have all benevolent
dictator
knowing and all wise and all
and benevolent
to coordinate all this stuff is it's
wonderful thinking but that's not the
way our institutions are set up
we have to understand those incentives
and understand how
people in those institutions are going
to react
and so
so that goes back to this issue that why
independence is important
why the fed has to protect it
when they asked me several years ago
when
they were recruiting a new chair i said
what do you think the most important
thing will be for the new chair
this is prior to powell's
appointment
i said the most the biggest most
important challenge
for the new fed chair will be protecting
the fed's independence
and i guess i would say
so far that's not going so well
no it's not and in defense of of the
time when we were both inside the fed
corporate bonds municipal bonds i mean
there were there were vigorous debates
and we as an institution then
resoundingly rejected
crossing that line and i recall that
there was a good bit of discussion about
even becoming involved in
mortgage-backed securities
because it it really was a form of
credit easing it was it was a way that
the fed was targeting a specific sector
and
and here we are today
uh with this gigantic debate about
mortgage-backed securities
and and what's happened for
the average u.s household entry-level
entry-level home buyers who really have
lost access uh to housing that has in
many ways been fueled uh by the
artificial repression of mortgage rates
um
i'm not sure how you feel about what
what side of that debate you you fall on
well i was never a fan of buying
mortgage-backed securities
that's a form of
credit allocation
which i am opposed to because it's
actually fiscal policy right now the fed
tried very hard
to make it sound like it was really
trying to do monetary policy
um
i mean the problem again was have it go
back to this big mandate they have
that big mandate
and broad powers
they can engage
can make a case
for almost any kind of intervention
in the financial markets in the name of
financial stability the dual mandate
they can justify doing almost anything
that goes back to what i was saying
earlier about the importance of having
constraints
on the range
herbs i
used to call it the range of authorities
of the fed
but the authorities keep expanding
the discretionary and willingness and
and rationale for intervening
in markets
gets expanded
and
um
rather than
being narrowly focused so that in fact
you can hold the fed account
you know i'll never
am i making sense here
no no no you're making perfect sense um
you just reminded me of a story that i
read
about 18 months ago
out of tokyo
and the head of the largest stock
exchange
actually publicly
um appealed to the bank of japan to
to to stop buying
uh stocks in the market because the
functionality of the stock market had
become so hampered
and
it again
it it goes to exemplify how slippery the
slope is
when
all of a sudden you go from treasuries
and qe1 and establishing financial
stability to high-yield bonds and stocks
and corporate bonds
well yeah and i mean and
and
everything
everything that i was worried about in
as we embarked on this
it's all coming true it's
worse
right and
i think that
i have a sense in which you know the
bigger the footprint of the fed and the
more engaged it is in intervening
in setting market prices of various
kinds
we've expanded the moral hazard problem
the fact the fed's creating huge moral
hazard problems
why is it seem to be true that
an eight trillion dollar balance sheet
hasn't solved the liquidity problems
when they used to be solved with an 800
billion dollar balance sheet right and
why is that well it's because
at least in part my hypothesis is
that as the bet as the fed grows and
displays
its willingness to backstop
and intervene
when prices and their view become out of
line
it means you get
more episodes where the fed feels like
it has to intervene
and they have to intervene in bigger
ways
and so rather than enhancing financial
stability
my sense is and this is debatable so but
my sense is that we've actually
aggravated it
and created an environment where
the fed
now thinks it has to intervene
more often
and in bigger ways
and i think that is
uh i mean that's a debatable proposition
but
um that's my sense and i don't think
it's a good outcome
uh i'll never forget richard had me um
richard had me write an entire briefing
document in 2010 about the implications
of
the default cycle the credit default
cycle in the corporate bond market being
cut short by qe and what problems that
might present a decade down the line if
the fed has had effectively kept
companies in business
that should have
in a non-intervened world restructured
and moved on and now we we actually have
twice as many what we call zombie
companies as we had prior to the
pandemic and now the corporate bond
market is approaching 11 and a half
trillion dollars yeah i think one of the
language things that i find interesting
over time
the notion of
the of the central bank being a lender
of last resort
was created it's a lender of last resort
to
depository and financial institutions
not everybody in the economy exactly and
it was a very narrowly focused concept
and and uh going back to badger ricardo
or uh
and others
um
and it's always meant that but somehow
the phrase lender of last resort has now
been co-opted
to mean oh well that means the fed
should lend as a last resort perhaps
even the first resort to anybody any
company in any market
and that's just the bastardization of
the term
and it's inappropriate
and yet people seem to now use it in
that light and i think that's really
unfortunate
um
i'm not sure if you have any any views
on um on some of the international
facilities that have been set up to
to really ensure liquidity swap lines
have been set up um do you think that in
the end this will
have any effect on on the demand for for
u.s treasuries and uh and i would take
one step further and and i'm not sure if
you've been following this or not it's
it's kind of arcane
uh it's kind of an arcane subject but
the idea of the central clearing of of
treasuries and kind of this path that
we're going down
uh
when it comes to ensuring the liquidity
that dried up in the treasury market in
march of 2020 to ensure that that
doesn't recur
yeah some of this is pretty arcane
you're right
but i would say the following um as a
general proposition
um
uh
i'm a believer
in
letting
prices
serve their purpose
which is to signal
scarcity or
surplus or whatever
um and
uh
i think this is another example
and i
i mean i understand the fed is
very much in central banks very much
committed to and feels it's important
to keep particularly the treasury market
functioning smoothly
i'm really not opposed to that
but
i am opposed to allowing that concept to
expand
ever wider
into other markets
um because that's where the moral hazard
comes
and that's
that's where you why you have episodes
like what was it september of 2019
you have these flare-ups
because
the fed has committed to intervening in
all sorts of markets
so
i guess i want to use the treasury
central as an example so that you have
to be careful how far you push
these concepts
right on the international side um
once again
i supported the swap lines during the
crisis i voted i wasn't going to draw a
line in the sand over those
i think that they were useful
but
unlike some people i didn't think they
came without cost
and um
you know the ecb
has
plenty of reserves
dollar reserves
it could draw on
to support european banks in their
dollar denominated demands
we didn't need to do a swap line
we just saved them the price
i mean i mean it could have been handled
i think
by certainly the ecb and probably the uk
as well
and japan
maybe some of the smaller central banks
around the world that could get access
to those swap lines
maybe that was appropriate
but
i do think this
tendency to treat everything
is a crisis
it calls for some intervention
prices move for a reason
and if you don't let them move
then the reallocations that have to
occur don't happen
and so um
i'm very much
a believer that
even in the financial markets that the
fed needs to let the price system
work
and to stop believing
that we know what those prices ought to
be
and to justify intervention on the
ground that we can get them right
i don't think we know what they ought to
be
much less get them right
and that's what the price system does
so i have a bias i'll admit it's a bias
to letting those prices move
frankly danielle we're talking about the
efficiency of monetary policy
if a repo rate
spikes 15 percentage points for one day
i don't as a monetary service and a
monetary policy maker i don't care
it won't make any difference to monetary
policy
um
and so i think we're too quick
to jump
and
think we have to do something about it
um
and there's huge pressure from financial
markets to do that as you know
oh yes
traders and others want their backs
covered
but that shouldn't be the role of the
fit
no you know when when when i try and
explain to a layperson and i don't even
understand all of zoltan pozar's old map
i've still got a copy of it um it takes
up half of a wall i don't i don't
understand it all later so
okay there you go
but when i when i try and explain to
people the magnitude of this reverse
repo facility that was 1.6 trillion
dollars today
um an all-time record i i
i try and paint them a picture of a of a
bucket
and i say well the fed's trying to fill
up the bucket from the top with 120
billion dollars of purchases every month
but yet the larger the reverse repo
facility gets the more holes are being
drilled into the bottom with liquidity
being drained out and
the comment is well they're only
overnight facilities they they go away
in 24 hours time but once you start to
get past a trillion and now we're
pushing into two trillion and they're
constant we say to yourself
well okay has the fed has clearly become
a major player
in
this corner of the market and now they
have a standing repo facility in the
event that the late 2019 events uh occur
once again it it it just feels like at
some point the fed's going to be the
entire market
well
i have some simply that point of view
it's a little bit like quacker mold
that uh
you know and every time it's like a mold
you expand your power
and intervention capabilities
um
and
which is back to what i said why i think
that this practice
may in fact be contributing
to volatility and instability
rather than enhancing it
and that's a very
um
difficult concept for some people to get
their head around
but i believe there's some truth to it
and
uh so
uh
so it's it's um
it's quite troubling to someone like me
who
has spent most of his life in economics
um
being an optimist
and believing in the power of markets to
work and
and resiliency of of a market economy
to see uh
i was heading down this path
that is
very uh
um
risky
at a minimum as far as i'm concerned
and yet
the train seems to be
you know
barreling down the tracks
to what may be a very uh unpleasant
conclusion
um
so there was in 10 years before you
joined the fed uh transcripts started
being taken
of fomc meetings
and if you look at a graph that the
saint louis fed
produces on a normal basis
dissents on the part of governors pretty
much fell off the map
and descends on the part of federal
reserve
district presidents started to go
started to increase in fact when you and
richard uh and and and honig and
you you you guys were the mavericks you
were that that was
that that was a an era of dissents that
we have not revisited
again
so
yeah i think this is um
i wrote a wall street journal editorial
in 2015
right after uh shortly after i retired
and and with editorials you don't get to
pick the title
the editors do that for you but
the title was the veneer of consensus
and i made this point that in fact
between
and 96
you had about
these are just round numbers 100
over that 20-year period
by governors
and about 100
by presidents
about equal balance
not quite but
between
1996 and today
there have been about another
hundred or so descents by presidents
two by governors
two in 25 years
mark olsen and oh my gosh
mark olsen and i i know we're good
friends i've seen him in dallas i can't
think of the second one
mark olson was the last one he was he
was the last one
that's a tremendous change in the
culture of the institution
and we can speculate as to why that's
come about
you know markets complain well you've if
you're descent you're
you're undermining the chair or we want
unanimity well how can you have
unanimity of 19 smart people
sitting in a room facing a crisis
they've never faced before
if you've got unanimity walter lipman
the journalist once said well all men
think of likes no one thinks very much
and
and the fear
that has been
um
or concerned
that has been placed on governors in
particular
to not dissent
i think it's a bad idea it's wrong
uh
the npc the bank of england's monetary
policy committee
is much better at this
mervin king
i talked about marvin king actually lost
votes occasionally during the crisis
2008 crisis
that did more
his willingness to lose a vote
did more for the credibility of the
institution
[Music]
than anything
he said this is this is a decision by an
institution
and we have a committee because we get
better decisions that way
that strengthened the institution
what's happened to the fed is the
pressure on governors not to dissent
so that it's always unanimous or
or
strongly you know uh
runs counter to building the credibility
of the institution
and not only that it's not transparent
the value of dissent
is that it makes transparent
the nature of the debates
and the issues the committee is facing
that's transparency and to hide that
transparency
under a con
under sort of a consensus statement
that's crafted to get everybody on board
i believe is dishonest
and counterproductive
and um
i think that um
we'd be better off trying to change that
culture if we could
and
i think
some of my colleagues and even past
chairs i've talked to about this
understand that but once you get in the
seat of the chair
it's hard to get
hard to do that
and it also means back to transparency
that means the statements that come out
by the fed
are not very informative
because they're trying to get everybody
to agree on this word or that word in
order to build as large a consensus as
you can
and that gradually takes the content out
right no i mean you you when you read
through transcripts you can read through
pages and pages and pages of of debate
on one word and you say to yourself is
this really happening these are grown
adults here in this room well it's
happening because they want to build
unanimity or consensus yep consensus is
i'm not against consensus
when it's there
right what i'm against
is building a consensus and hiding the
debate in order to make it a consensus
right right
no that's a that's a critical
distinction um
so
tell me where you think we are with the
big inflation word right now
because it is it is one of the most
hotly debated um
subjects and the whole transitory
persistent
supply chain
i mean you know
at last check you know a rent is 12
months in length so uh if rents are
rising at 10 year-over-year which they
are
uh to me that seems like it's a long it
it might feed through with with of
course with a lag but that it might feed
through into inflation for a persistent
period
well uh yes i i so
i think the issue is uh or the number of
issues
i don't think there's any question
that some of this
is uh
due
to bottlenecks or supply constraints
there's clearly some of that i'm not
denying that sure but in some ways
that's not the interesting question and
it's and the question that i see the fed
avoiding
is answering the question
of
well
what does role does policy play
in other words
my view is that
whether this
spike in inflation
turns out to be
more persistent
that will be determined not by the price
of lumber or the price of rents or used
cars
that's going to be determined by policy
that is
if the fed
the fed and the
physical authorities
we're in the most accommodated state
in 100 or 80 years anyway
and to me
as a policy maker
i would be deeply and am deeply
concerned as to whether or not
my policy actions
are going to determine the path of
inflation look people don't like me or
other people raising the 1970s
but what did we do in the 1970s we had
big physical deficits from the great
society and vietnam war we had
oil embargoes
supply shocks livestock
bottlenecks that were caused by
the scarcity of oil and the price of oil
what did the fed do
the fed tried to keep
those supply shocks from adversely
affecting
unemployment
it kept monetary policy very easy even
tried wage and price controls
but in the end
they took those transitory shocks
and supply shocks
increased
monetary policy and aggregate demand
through monetary policy and translate
those supply shocks into more persistent
inflation
so the question
they keep saying well it's going to be
temporary to be going away
that's not what i want to hear from the
fed
i want to hear
how are they how is their policy going
to make sure
that it's transitory
right rather than making sure it's going
to be more persistent
and the fed will not it does not like
answering that question
and every time you've heard powell talk
about it in a press conference
he says oh well it's
you know it's the price of lumber or you
know the price of automobiles and it's
going to go away
well okay what does that tell me about
what does it tell you about what you
ought to do as a policy maker
don't deflect
this away from policy
your job is policy
so tell me what policy role policy is
playing in this
and inevitably he'll say nothing
but you know that's got to be wrong
so uh
will the fed get lucky
maybe
but if they but
their problem is is that they stated
we're not going to raise rates until
we reach full employment that's their
problem
that was not in their playbook
and inflation and
higher than desired unemployment
and now they've got to figure out a way
to get out of this
so so that is the ultimate
that's the ultimate question right now
on markets minds i mean it is the fed in
a taper trap
to where they
you know it's going to be
or a policy error
well
but that's right what they've done the
fed has done this to themselves
what they have done they put themselves
in a spot
and they didn't do it intentionally but
they should have known better put
themselves in a spot that says well if
we
turn to fight inflation
we are releasing on our promise
to not raise rates until
full employment
you lose credibility
if they stick to their
commitment about employment
and they don't address inflation
and inflation goes up
then they've engaged on their commitment
to inflation
it's lose lose
they put themselves in a spot
where
they they're gonna they
conceivably will look bad either way
so what are they doing they're doing
nothing
and ordering a lot of nothing
to avoid making a commitment one way or
another and hoping for the best
well hope isn't a strategy as far as i'm
concerned but they're hoping for the
best so they they put themselves in this
dilemma
that they created for themselves
through
what i consider to be their
poorly designed new strategy
and guidance that they've left
and now they're struggling to what to do
i don't think the taper matters
i'm not a big fear i don't have big
fears of taper tantrums they ought to
just do it and get on with it
because eventually they're going to have
to raise they're probably going to have
to raise rates
and the longer they put paper off
the longer they're going to delay
raising rates and the bigger hole
they're going to dig for themselves
so um i'm tapering
is useful
they probably should have stopped it six
months ago or a year ago
but um
at least
but uh it's useful because it will send
a signal to the markets that the fed is
concerned which is
a good useful thing to do
but
stopping or tapering and stopping
purchases
i don't think will be satisfactory
in stopping
continuously the continued inflation
risks
so the fed tries to hide
to
think of itself as this big risk manager
they think oh we're managing risk but
here they've got this huge risk of
inflation
that they're not managing at all
they're just hoping it goes away
and uh
so
i just think they've created a huge
dilemma for themselves
and i don't believe this new strategy is
going to
last much longer
it's not really a long-term strategy
it's going to work they're going to have
to revisit it at some point
um but
i think it was a mistake to begin with
well um so so i have to ask because it's
one of the most pressing pressing issues
of the day
uh you were in attendance at an
emergency federal open market committee
meeting
in october of 2013.
and at that meeting
there was a blueprint drawn out as to
how the treasury department could
strategically default
on
on treasuries in the event of of the
debt ceiling not being resolved
and the fed taking the risk out of
a foreign holder or
a pension fund let's say
missing an interest payment by by making
sure that it stayed within the purview
of the fed and it's now what does it
hold 25 percent of treasuries today
so um
i guess
two things one is that
the way the fed thinks about this
in general
is that
it's about
mostly about financial stability
in the sense that it wants to keep it
would like to see that one doesn't want
to see
the u.s treasury market
you know blow up on them
you can kind of understand that
yes
yes you can
uh but
having said that
the
proposals that are being bounded around
that go back to that 2013
discussion
they're kind of two versions of it
one is is that
the fed
would
buy up
defaulted or
non-paying
treasuries
at a market price
at a market price that's key here
we buy them up at market prices
and
hopefully with the idea that it would
only be temporary and that they would
refill them out
another version of that
was that is that they wouldn't buy them
they would
just
take in defaulted securities
now i think those are very different
um
plans
but my concern is is that this is all
for the most part
bailouts and smoking mirrors in the
following sense
what does it mean to buy a defaulted
security at a market price
well if there's a market price for it
why do you need to buy it at all at the
market price because somebody else will
buy it at the market price
and
i mean
i mean what what what does that really
do
what it doesn't do at least in my view
um
and you know me i tend to be an old
prophet tonight in some ways you know
one of the old guys but
it doesn't save the u.s
sovereign
debt
or let me say it a different way it
doesn't really
mean
that the u.s hasn't defaulted on
sovereign debt
right it's still the false fiction
moody's would follow s p in a heartbeat
if even i mean they would still be it
would still
the us's reputation
for defaulting on its sovereign debt
would not be solved
by these strategies
right the reputational risk
and credit risk
of the us government would be damaged no
m in either case even they didn't do
anything right
so
these strategies are not really solving
the debt crisis
they're just kind of rearranging some
deck chairs a bit
but the reputational risk and what
you're really afraid of
is the reputational and credit risk
of the treasury market of the treasury
debt
and this doesn't solve that
it may tie things over temporarily
but
so
i'm not sure this is a particularly good
idea
in fact i'm pretty sure it isn't
because i also think that it creates a
vast amount of
moral hazard again
of where central banks are trying to
bail out their
their sovereigns
right and it seems to me didn't
argentina just try this and hasn't a lot
of countries done this before in some
fashion or another using monetary policy
to protect against sovereign debt crises
it doesn't work right
no it doesn't so i don't think this
really solves anything
there may be people in the markets that
you talk to all the time i'm sure who
would love
to have this this backstop forum
but it doesn't solve the fundamental
problem
of
the default
by the us government
and so
i don't i i think it's probably it's
probably not a good idea to pursue this
in my view
um
and hopefully it won't come to that but
i tell you that
the case that the fed can make
the the fed is incredibly incredibly
creative that's the word i'm looking for
really creative
uh in in sometimes a good way
but creative
and
and figuring out ways to justify
all sorts of interventions it could come
up with that would be legal or
quote desirable
there's no limit on how creative they
can become
and this is back to where we started
some of this conversation about the
expanding mandate it's true sovereign
debt is probably more important than
some things but still
i
i'm
this was such a terrible signal to other
countries
who may have sovereign debt crises
and their solution
really want to encourage other countries
to behave that way
i don't think so
so i i'm i'm i'm pretty dubious
well so my final question would be uh
is there a way out
is there a way out for the fed is there
is there a theoretical soft landing
to where
you're not going to take the s p down by
and tapering will be
welcomed and people will be rational
about rate hikes and it just
is there a way out for the fed
um
well
i'm not sure
i'm not sure i know the answer that
maybe
i think my frustration with the fed over
the years
has been that
they keep digging this hole
um and what was the old theo saying you
know the first time when you're in a
hole is to stop digging right
well they just keep digging them deeper
themselves deeper and deeper into this
morass
of intervention
moral hazard and backstops
fiscal policy
actions
and
um i mean i argued back in 2010 and i
still believe both these would be wise
what they really need to do is tell the
fed a
your primary mandate is price stability
b
your portfolio should be all treasuries
and c you need a new credit accord which
i described back in 2009 a credit accord
that says
the fed does not do credit allocation
and that if an emergency comes about
it's the treasurer's responsibility
they need to be held accountable for it
and the feds should be held harmless and
protected
against engaging in bad or even good
fiscal policy right
those three steps would do things like
narrow the fed scope
protect them from digging these holes
that we've been talking about i've been
talking about
and perhaps restore some credibility
and
accountability
to uh what the fed
does and his health responsible for
but
expanding the mandates
doing fiscal policy
bailing out governments and creditors
are going in the wrong direction in my
view
well i i i share your views charlie um
but i
am also
so grateful that you were able to spend
so much time
uh really
tearing down and explaining in language
that that everybody can understand
kind of what what the roots are and it's
good to know that there are thinkers out
there like you because there are indeed
ways that you can restore credibility
and accountability
at the fed and i just i want to thank
you so much for spending so much time
with me this afternoon it was really a
pleasure well thank you daniel it was a
lot of fun hopefully hopefully i
stimulated some people to think about
things a bit i'm i'm quite positive you
did charlie i'm quite positive take good
care all right thank you bye-bye bye-bye
so that was pretty incredible uh i have
to say that that was the first
uh federal reserve district president
i've i've ever interviewed and i can't
thank charlie for giving me as much time
as he did and it's beautiful to see that
he still thinks as sharply as he ever
did and that his opinions are as
critical as they should be
given the tumultuous time that we're
going through
um with really the marriage of the
treasury department and the federal
reserve so i i hope you enjoy it as as
much as as as i did
if you want somebody who's even more
outspoken about federal reserve policy
and much less held back
less diplomatic if you will uh then you
might want to consider going back and
watching a recent episode of down the
middle that i did with peter bookvar i
think you'd find that to be of interest
as well as always i want to thank you
for your time and i look forward to the
next episode of down the middle this is
danielle dimartino booth thank you
[Music]